[Musik]
durch den landtagswahlkampf im freistaat
sachsen 2090 scheint ein kleiner ruck zu
gehen der fast alle parteien erfasst weg
mit dem frust des flüchtlings jahres
2015 weg von einem angst wahlkampf mehr
haltung mehr optimismus mehr mut die
parteien suchen ein gegengewicht zur
deaf.de die sich anschickt politische
fundamente im freistaat sachsen zu
verschieben ist die volksabstimmung
darüber ob sachsen deutschland hier in
sachsen war die erste in ihren ersten
landtag eingezogen weil der
bundestagswahl vor zwei jahren wurde sie
hier stärkste kraft und auch bei den
letzten europawahlen lag sie in sachsen
vorn und nun geht es wieder von den
landtag
es gibt überhaupt gar keine garantie
dass wir diese stimmung in sachsen die
nach rechts tendiert die eine frust
stimmung ist eine angst stimmung ist
dass die wir dass wir die besiegen
können es gibt keine garantie dass kann
verloren gehen das ist eine wirklich
entscheidende wahlentscheidung in diesem
jahr in sachsen von sachsen gegen vor 30
jahren die friedliche revolution aus
sachsen brachte vor fünf jahren pegi
daher vor dem land scheint eine trotzige
kraft inne zu wohnen die sich nun wieder
erregt weil sich hier nach dem rausch
des mauerfalls etwas angestaut hat hier
zeigen sich auch webfehler der
wiedervereinigung
man hat gesagt mit der deutschen einheit
ist alles super alle sind vereinigt und
damit sind jetzt alle demokraten weil
natürlich auch gesagt wurde die
ostdeutschen haben die friedliche
revolution erkämpft und deswegen sind
das jetzt alles demokraten
das war natürlich mitnichten so es ist
die politik die politik anfang der 90er
jahre die zugelassen hat dass hier
dieser raubbau passiert ist ich glaube
schon dass es auch ein trugschluss der
politik war zu glauben also wenn die
generation die das miterlebt hatten
rente gegangen
dann kommt gibt sie neu für die spielt
ost und west keine rolle mehr
und so hat sich durch eine
wechselseitige bewegung so dieses
grundgefühl eingeprägt wir ostdeutschen
werden wohl für immer deutsche zweiter
klasse bleiben
es sind wieder viele leute die bewusst
die wände miterlebt haben die eben auch
gesagt haben wir haben uns damals was
vorschreiben lassen müssen damals vom
sed-regime und die fühlen sich eben
jetzt wieder und irgendeine art
bevormundet und das wollen die leute
nicht was ist los in diesem blühenden
bundesland mit sie einen sanierten
städten und den top pisa-ergebnissen
woher kommen frust wut und protest
verhalten von dem die afg hier im osten
so profitiert ich glaube der großen
unterschied zwischen ost und
westdeutschland ist tatsächlich die
menschen hier die haben eine diktatur
erlebt die haben erlebt wie man sollte
seinen offiziellen aussagen misstrauen
muss sie sind nicht so obrigkeitshörig
sie sind noch nicht so zum medien treu
sage ich mal
dort kommt unser unsere zustimmung her
und das hat schon was aus spezifisches
[Musik]
ein früheres abend 2009/10 im
sächsischen grimma besuch aus berlin hat
sich angekündigt das sind afd
bundestagsmitglieder auch tino kuba ist
dabei der im sächsischen
landtagswahlkampf mitmischt themen
finden sich für die afg bei solchen
abenden von selbst beispiel russland
sanktionen in ostdeutschland wir sind
sehr verbunden mit russland weil wir
viele viele firmen haben die für
russland gearbeitet haben und wir haben
viele kollegen junge kollegen die noch
in betrieben sind die mit russland noch
gearbeitet haben wo sind die ganzen
verträge hinweg und dann regt man sich
auf das in ostdeutschland in sachsen die
wirtschaft nicht wächst das ist die
schnelle vorwärts geht ja aber wenn man
uns die füße weg ab was soll dabei
rauskommen
die afg erklärt dem publikum bei solchen
abenden was sie im bundestag genau macht
welche wege anträge nehmen und warum es
manchmal so lange dauert bis ein gesetz
durch ist
sie erklärt wie politik funktioniert und
holt damit ihre wähler genau dort ab wo
sie stehen
politische inhalte kommen dabei fast von
selbst und wie so oft bei afg
veranstaltungen geht es auch um
flüchtlinge
ich bin jetzt wieder nazi ich weiß
hört sich so an ja meine frage ist kann
man da nicht was ändern dass die
deutschen geht ich vorrangig behandelt
werden als die asylanten also es wird
mit zweierlei maß gemessen weil eben
immer noch die geschichte von 50 im
hintergrund steht das ist schwer zu
ertragen das geht mir genauso
und ich finde schon dass wir hier über
änderungen nachdenken müssen und zwar
schleunigst an der afg wird es nicht
liegen um das mal ganz klar zu sagen
der bundestagsabgeordnete timo grub
allah will die herrschaft der cdu in
sachsen brechen derzeit wird die afg mit
etwa 25 prozent gehandelt die starke
dominanz der cdu die sachsen drei
jahrzehnte prägte ist geschichte in
sachsen hat er ja die zierliche zum
anfangs sogar die absolute mehrheit
kurz nach der wende und hat sicherlich
auch eine gute aufbauarbeit mit kopien
kopf gemacht aber dann kam er im prinzip
die dekadenz und auch die die arroganz
der macht ins spiel ja man hat gedacht
es läuft weiter die sachsen werden der
mann cdu und man hat aber insgesamt auch
für den ländlichen raum gemerkt die
unzufriedenheit auch wächst in der
bevölkerung dass viele versprechungen
immer eingehalten von wahlversprechen
nicht eingehalten worden
und das hat schon die bürger man hat sie
auch vernachlässig man hat gedacht das
läuft so weiter und man hat uns
natürlich auch nach 2017 ganz klar
unterschätzt das muss man auch sagen für
die gäste im saal trifft die afd
den richtigen ton und den nerv der zeit
ihre wähler sehen die partei fast als
eine art heilsbringerin bundes doch
kommt ich gucke mir wirklich spaß ich
mache mir das wirklich manchmal ich
gucke mir alles an wenn ich muss ehrlich
sagen die einzigen die mir wirklich
gefallen
das ist die ofd weidlich vielen den
spiegel vorhalten und die wollen das
auch nicht machen und viele grimma
stellen an diesem abend auch fest dass
tatsächlich etwas passiert ist seitdem
die afd den politikbetrieb aufmischt in
sachsen gerät wirklich etwas in bewegung
jetzt schon bei den anderen parteien
ich bin selber aktiv an der freiwilligen
feuerwehr und bin dort selber ja leider
tätig und wir waren zum empfang
bürgermeisters dieses jahr gewesen und
optisch funktionär aber dort umgesehen
die hatte ich vorher noch nie gesehen
musste ich persönlich fahrt nachfragen
da sind sie dann nicht ab die noch nie
gesehen aber die kunden 20 kilometer von
direkt- und das ist eigentlich das aus
die afg streichelt die sachsen seele und
verbreitet aufbruchstimmung den saal in
grimma durchzieht am ende tatsächlich so
etwas wie eine kleine euphorie traurig
geht hier heute abend niemand nach hause
der moderator entlässt seine gäste fast
weh popstar kino kruppa und seine
antwort auf die frage was gerade den
sachsen für die afd so empfänglich macht
denke wer unbedingt misstrauischer als
kritischer insgesamt kritischer
hinterfragt auch viel mehr lässt sich
natürlich auch keine denk- und sprach
verbote auf order of the dog trainieren
also was das merkt man in vielen in
vielen bereichen wir sagen einfach was
wir denken der sachse sagt was er denkt
und lässt sich auch nicht gerne
bevormunden und wenn probleme auftreten
dann benennt er sehr hoch ganz klar und
deutlich
und dann kommt natürlich zum teil das
ist die kritik an den medien dann wird
man mit kritischen meinung wenn man
gegen der regierung eine andere meinung
vertritt sofort in die rechte ecke
gestellt oder wird abgestempelt als
populist was ich als politiker darf die
selber erlebe ja aber das mittlerweile
verfängt das nimmer dass die bürger
wissen und können sehr wohl einschätzen
was real ist und was nicht real ist was
real ist und was nicht reell ist die
deutungshoheit darüber nahm ab herbst
2014 auch päda für sich in anspruch ein
unbeholfenes wort konstrukt aber eines
das zur marke werden sollte patriotische
europäer gegen die islamisierung des
abendlandes die gründer dieser bewegung
wänden deutschland offenbar auf dem
besten weg in eine art kalifat ich rede
ja von der schrittweisen abschaffung
christlichen kulturgutes aus unserer
gesellschaft wie in berlin und anderen
städten bereits begonnen
so ist zb der weihnachtsmarkt umbenannt
in einen winter mord um religiöse
gefühle nicht zu
doch den menschen die sich anschlossen
ging es um mehr als nur islamisierung
die neue demonstrations- form zog
tausende in ihren bann
es zeigte sich plötzlich und mit wucht
wie viel offenbar für viele im argen lag
durch dresdens straßen wehte ein hauch
von 1989
diesmal genau so dass sie keine rechte
das sind ganz normale leute wie jeder
sie und ich auch das sind wirklich wir
haben immer etwas bedenken
ich kann nur sagen dass ich die bewegung
in ordnung finde
solange es keine rechten und hooligans
das aussetzen
ob ein tanzen kann ich an meinen kleinen
leben einfach sagen dass ich mich sehr
ungerecht und diesen startbahn gefühle
peggy da erlebt geisterhafte zuwächse
aus vielen politischen richtungen aber
mit den themen islamisierung und asyl
zieht peter auch das rechte lager an für
beobachter ist das nicht zu übersehen
mittlerweile zeigt sich auch deutlicher
einerseits wir haben ganz klar
rechtsextremisten die hier mitlaufen
die auch ja bro'sis tische positionen
schüren
wir haben die hooligan-szene deutlich
erkennbar
sie haben dann aber immer noch auch eine
große gruppe von menschen die offenbar
keinen anderen ort in der demokratie
finden als hier um ihre noch ziemlich
undifferenzierten diffusen unmut zum
ausdruck zu bringen und die muss man
anhören
die muss man ernst nehmen frank richter
war als bürgerrechtler im herbst 89 auf
der straße erkennt dresden das pedal
fast ausschließlich rechts verordnet
wurde hält er für eine ost west problem
wir haben uns täuschen lassen in der
ersten zeit
ich glaube ich gehörte zu den ersten die
gesagt haben vorsicht an der
bahnsteigkante hier hat sich vieles
angesammelt wir können das nicht
eindeutig zuordnen
die westdeutsche die kommentatoren und
auch die beobachter waren desto besser
seien zahlen die vermeintlich das ist
hierbei um rechtsextremisten handelt
nazis im nadelstreifen das waren alles
zuweisungen aus der ferne den
organisatoren von peggy da hätte damals
nichts besseres passieren können als
diese oberflächlichen billigen
wohlfeilen und falschen zuweisungen denn
damit drängte man ein großteil der
menschen eben tatsächlich in diese ecke
in die sie am anfang jedenfalls in toto
noch nicht gehörten
peter both den demonstranten am anfang
vor allem auch ein ventil für angestaute
zweifel eine art zuhause ein gefühl der
gemeinschaft zusammengehalten von der
gewissheit dass hier irgendetwas im land
nicht stimmen könne
peggy da zog damit auch die an die am
grundsätzlichen zweifeln an der
staatsordnung und dem grundgesetz
zweifel die der beobachter versuch zu
zerstreuen
entstanden ist das von der mental ist es
heißt grundgesetz eine verfassung
anderen staat und combos wollen wir noch
im zweiten begriff dafür haben muss man
sich ja nicht zusammen
ich wiederhole beispiel sorgen machen ob
das kind richtigerweise danach patzte
zeigte peggy dagegen über keine
berührungsängste
der politologe selbst cdu-mitglied gilt
als nationalkonservativ und agiert auf
dem schmalen grat zwischen verstehen
wollen und verständnis haben
peggy gänger zeigen sich allein dafür
schon dankbar
nach gut also hier noch zu jung stehe
überhaupt kraft und dann gibt es meine
frau weiterhin eine frau ginge das alles
wissen
da wünsche ich allen einen schönen rest
des nachmittags zum guten nachhauseweg
für die zeit bis nächsten montag hat das
gemutmasst epg der nähe sollte später zu
seinem ausscheiden aus der tu dresden
beitragen der politologe selbst hat mit
dem stigma peggy da versteh kein problem
sein blick auf die protestbewegung war
immer ein eigener es ist nicht so als ob
er sozusagen die unterschicht wäre die
hilfsarbeiter arbeitslosen
nein das ist nicht so es sind leute die
solide berufe meistens im technischen
oder wirtschaftlichen bereich haben es
gibt auch etliche aus dem handwerker
proletariat beziehungsweise aus dem
selbstständigen proletariat die dabei
sind aber auch vom bildungsstand her
es sind leute mit universitätsabschluss
handwerksmeister usw
die dort demonstrieren und aus der wende
erfahrung ist das prägende folgendes wir
haben schon einmal erlebt wie ein system
das auf falschen prämissen gegründet war
zusammengebrochen ist
diese erfahren möchten eigentlich nicht
noch einmal machen deswegen möchten wir
dass die politische klasse falsche
politik unterlässt von der pdk des
jahres 2015 ist heute nur ein harter
kern geblieben aber es gibt sie noch
der protest von der straße hat
inzwischen über die ard den weg in die
parlamente gefunden und nun läuft für
die parteien der kampf um die wähler
und das schon seit monaten wir sind in
auerbach im vogtland ganz im westen
sachsens die cdu tourte schon im
frühjahr durchs land und sammelte ideen
der basis die dann ins
landtagswahlprogramm einflossen so viel
bürgernähe und basisdemokratie gab es
früher nicht
doch nicht nur ihre wähler kamen der
sächsischen cdu abhanden sondern auch
parteimitglieder wie jens bunzel der
sich nach 41 jahren in der cdu nun
ausgerechnet der afg angeschlossen hat
den selbständigen handwerker erwarten in
ein paar jahren nur etwas über 500 euro
rente sagt er
geld für flüchtlinge paarung oder in den
letzten jahren geld zu flüchtlingen
gemacht haben haben wir nicht einen dort
diskutiert da haben wir einfach etwas
gab teilen mir milliarden und jetzt wenn
wir über die andere reden
reden wir schon 20 jahre und haben nur
warum es setze und
wenn sie in selbstständigen ja der sich
selbständig macht sorgen soll vorsorgen
da hat dann an der in seiner ersten
seite dazu denn über halb das stück
produkt helfen können da denkt nicht ein
rande der muss auch mehr sender in
betriebs- und laufen zu bringen
und wenn auch das hingebracht hat dann
kann der wald oder sonst was ein so sein
sollte dass die cdu in sachsen daran
noch etwas ändern glaubt jens bunzel
nicht außerdem regiert die partei schon
seit dem mauerfall ohne pause entweder
allein oder mit einem kleinen
koalitionspartner für bunzel hat sich
zuviel eingeschliffen in sachsen sowieso
aber auch überhaupt es ist einfach diese
diese verkrusteten strukturen dieser
demo die cdu
das ist ein schöner sicher richtig
kennen wenn dir angela sorgt es wird
grün gestrichen der greifen alles enorm
von der spricht keiner drüber jeder will
seinen posten erhält sein geld weiter
gering und der schein trügt denn das
pastoren es ist interessant und menschen
die jens bunzel doch noch zurück zu
holen hat sich die cdu in sachsen
prominent verstärkt so treffen wir ein
auerbach werner patzelt wieder seine
professur an der tu dresden lief in
diesem jahr aus also wechselte er die
seiten und ging direkt ins
wahlkampfschlager bastelt hat er seine
partei als beobachter immer scharf
kritisiert nun also holt ihn die cdu ins
team natürlich mit kalkül
die positive vision lautet dass die cdu
eingesehen hat dass die kritik die ich
jahrelang an ihren verhaltensweisen
geübt habe die dazu geführt hat dass
rechts von der union eine andere partei
stark geworden ist dass diese kritik zu
traf und dass man sich nun den geholt
hat der bislang nur theoretisch
behauptet hat zu wissen wie es geht dass
er tatsächlich hand anlegt und für die
partei etwas tut die boshafte version
ist die dass ich zu denen aus der cdu
gehöre bei denen wähler der afd nicht
gleich die schotten dicht machen sondern
noch zu hören
und womit auch argumentativ erreichbar
sind und das ist natürlich eine aufgabe
die ich gerne übernehme damit der trend
zum rechtspopulismus in deutschland
gestoppt wird
das in auerbach cheerleader erwarten
dass hatte sachsens ministerpräsident
vermutlich nicht auf dem zettel und ihr
wunsch ihn hoch zu heben scheint ihm
unbehagen zu bereiten
andererseits auch das ist wahlkampf und
michael gritsch mehr weiß natürlich dass
es da auch um die richtigen bilder geht
die siegeswillen zeigen oder
entschlossenheit oder optimismus je
nachdem gerade in diesen zeiten in
sachsen für die ernsten themen sorgt
drinnen das saalpublikum es fragt nach
kaputten straßen dem langsamen internet
oder nach den vielen ärzten lehrern und
polizisten die in sachsen fehlen
heftige debatten wie noch vor drei
jahren um flüchtlinge oder asyl bleiben
aus oder dienen nur noch als
steilvorlage
auf die frage warum straffälliger
asylbewerber in plauen oft nicht
abgeschoben werden zeigt kretschmer
seine andere seite ergibt sich
unerbittlich und präsentiert sich als
hardliner
die brauchen wir andere instrumente vor
allen dingen wenn sie sich daneben
benehmen für diejenigen die sich hier
vernünftig verhalten da kann man sagen
ist halt so aber diejenigen die
kriminell werden die klauen oder so mit
die können sich aus meiner sicht dann
nicht mehr einfach draußen herum bewegen
und uns alle miteinander terrorisieren
und vor allen dingen auch für die gruppe
der asylbewerber dann auch noch zum
problem werden weil alle dann auf die
zeigen sagen guck mal wie die sind
kretschmers botschaft an seine cdu basis
ist klar
geht raus und sagt den wählern dass es
die cdu im griff hat und dass es eine
afd in sachsen gar nicht braucht doch
die angst die wahl zu verlieren auch
heute abend hier in auerbach schwebt sie
im raum
ich engagiere mich ja und sprechen mit
vielen leuten und kriegt immer wieder
das gleiche problem
januar macht doch nicht lasst doch die
verbrecher hafen und ihr der ofd die
horchte fonds und da bitte ich das ist
schon paradox da ging das los dass man
die nicht mit ins boot geholt hat dass
man in keiner verantwortung übertragen
hat die keinen gutschein die haben eine
verantwortung und das ist eigentlich
mein problem jetzt die angst vor wahlen
schauen sie es gibt den alten deutschen
satz wer nicht hören will muss fühlen
als in dresden einige tausend im kreis
zu laufen begonnen und irgendwann auch
riefen wollten viele leute nicht hören
weil das was zu hören gewesen wäre
passte nicht ins weltbild nämlich dass
es wirklich probleme gebe mit
einwanderung bei wahlen aber haben sich
auch solche die den gregor gysi niemals
gewählt hätten sein richtiges wort zu
eigen gemacht in der wahlkabine schau
dir niemand zu da könnte das kreuz
machen wo ihr wollt und somit fühlen
jetzt politische parteien nicht zuletzt
unsere partei dasjenige was zuvor nicht
hören wollten
das war der fehler nicht zuzuhören nicht
das eingebildete verwirklichen zu
unterscheiden nicht das rein logisch
irrationale vom realen zu unterscheiden
und auf das reale die wichtigen probleme
so zu reagieren dass seitens der
bevölkerung zuversicht entsteht die da
oben haben tatsächlich noch alle tassen
im schrank und lösen die probleme die
sie zum teil selbst mitverursacht haben
ob es ihnen gelingt das ruder
herumzureißen weiß hier keiner
umfragen sahen die afg in diesem jahr
mit der cdu lange auf augenhöhe und
damit stellte sich auch die frage nach
einer zusammenarbeit michael kretschmer
sei ein klares nein dazu und sein warum
nicht
die afg ist im sächsischen landtag und
jeder der will kann sehen was sie da tut
oder was sie nicht tut und ich habe
immer gesagt es reicht ein halber tag
und sich das anhören die reden und dann
sind wir alle geheult weil das ist es
hat eine aggressivität eine bösartigkeit
auch so eine abschätzig kite dass das
sind alles keine leute mit denen sie
gerne familien geburtstag verbringen
würden denn nicht alle wenn wir jetzt
die andrucke wäre ja alles für den
landtag kandidierte das ist keine
normalisierung sondern die radikalen
kräfte bekommen immer mehr zulauf
kretschmers botschaften ja wir haben
fehler gemacht ja wir haben den wählern
zu wenig zugehört das alles ist
verstanden das ändern wir nun ergibt
sich optimistisch und hofft dass er auf
diese weise nach der wahl um die heikle
frage nach einer koalition mit der fdp
werde noch einmal herum kommt
weihnachten 2014 päda lädt zum
weihnachtssingen
npd-mitglieder mischen sich unter das
volk und versuchen sich an die neue
bürgerbewegung heranzuwachsen fast
sinnbildlich erinnern sie daran dass der
protest in sachsen nicht aus dem nichts
kam die idee hatte natürlich eine
vorgeschichte insbesondere in dresden
also spätestens seit anfang der
nullerjahre waren wir froh nisch gesagt
sarkastisch gesagt in dresden gut
versorgt mit rechtsextremistischen
demonstrationen die sich meistens um den
13 februar herum ergaben
gemeint sind die demonstrationen zum
jahrestag der bombenangriffe vom februar
1945 die stadt tat sich lange schwer
einheitlich dagegen aufzutreten sie
prägten lange vor p dass dresden wird
und schon 2004 wählten die sachsen die
npd in den landtag zehn jahre hielt sich
die partei dort es passte also einfach
alles ins bild pd das nur eine weitere
rechte bewegung im ohnehin rechten
sachsen
die politik reagierte dünnhäutig vor
allem auf den pedibus wir sind das volk
das das da missbraucht wird von dieser
komischen mischpoke diesen spruch
missbrauchen
die montagsdemonstration für ihre zwecke
denn einerseits muss man natürlich
aufbauen aufpassen dass man denjenigen
die da durchaus auch als rattenfänger
unterwegs sind nicht auf den leim geht
ich schätze mich glücklich von soviel
raten wir euch umgeben zu sein
ja ihr habt richtig gehört raten ihr
seid laut innenminister ulbig ratten
er bittet alle mitglieder des orga teams
von tiger öffentlich als rattenfänger
und somit sind die leute die heute hier
unserem aufruf gefolgt sind raten
[Musik]
lange zeit reichte es jemanden in
deutschland zu sagen so wie du redest
räten rates und du willst doch keiner
sein
dann hat er sich gesagt nein ich will
auch keiner sein ich bin kann ich werde
vorsichtig reden nachdem das am anfang
funktioniert der aber dann mehr leute
begriffen moment ich werde nun
behauptete als sei ich ein nazi ich bin
es aber nicht die sache dann irgendwann
ich kann mich gut an einem brief
erinnern denen ich bekam damals der
lautete sinngemäß herr richter ich war
einmal im ganzen leben noch nie ein nazi
aber ich bin jetzt von politikern und
auch von politologen dreimal viermal als
nazi bezeichnet wurden wissen sie jetzt
bin ich ein
das hat eine wirklich ein trotz
ausgelöst einen widerstand das weiß man
von seiner hausfrauen psychologie wenn
man ein kind dauernd beschimpft dann
wird dieses kind ein irgendwann einmal
so bockig werden das ist möglicherweise
auch zurückschlägt und dieser
psychologischen mechanismus hat sich
damals abgespielt
auch frank richter hat inzwischen die
seiten gewechselt vom beobachter zum
akteur
es sind eben hoch politische zeiten in
sachsen richter mischt auf der liste der
spd im landtagswahlkampf mit auch die
genossen treibt die frage nach dem
rechtsruck um und danach was die politik
hier in sachsen in den letzten
jahrzehnten vielleicht dazu beigetragen
hat sachsen war jahrelang schlusslicht
deutschlandweit es schließlich zb
internationale jugendarbeit und zwar mit
abstand
wir haben damals auch gesagt wo soll das
hinführen und weltoffenes sachsen war
eine reaktion darauf aber die kommen
meiner meinung nach viel viel zu spät
also da ist auch mit ansage demokratie
bildnerisch schaden angerichtet worden
die spd gastiert an diesem
frühlingsabend in böhlen in ostsachsen
im südraum von leipzig
zu ddr zeiten wurde hier braunkohle
veredelt das örtliche kraftwerk prägt
bis heute die silhouette der stadt eine
region mitten im strukturwandel die tage
worten von einst werden sich zu einer
seenlandschaft verbinden städte wie
bohlen stellen sich diesem wandel und
dennoch 2017 hat hier in dieser region
jeder vierte die afg gewählt das
publikum bei der spd weiß nicht warum
doch das thema ist auch für sie
allgegenwärtig selbst in meinem
bekanntenkreis
ich brauche es dann zum geburtstag zum
beispiel der trend nach rechts das geht
gar nicht böse von leuten die der wenig
also ich unterste schicht sind selbst
leute die die relativ mittelmäßig gut
dastehen
die haben sicher also ich kann mit
diesen leuten nicht klar muss ich
ehrlich sagen tatsächlich so mit den
leuten mit denen ich zum geburtstag
gesprochen habe
das ist schon die mittelschicht also das
war noch meister und so weiter und die
gehen davon aus dass hier was nicht
stimmt in deutschland liberalen
hinterher aber dass sie alle zum
beispiel große wagen der mittelklasse
wagen fahren oder sowas sowas denn die
zum beispiel nicht da kann ja auch nicht
einfach bis zum herunterfallen
sachsens spd chef martin dulig tod schon
seit fünf jahren mit seinem küchentisch
durchs land wer will kann platz nehmen
und fragen stellen auch für das spd
publikum in berlin spielen flüchtlinge
und asyl und migration keine rolle mehr
2015 liegt eben weit zurück die
flüchtlingskrise bewältigt in polen geht
es um renten um löhne um kita plätze
oder umbildung der parteichef sieht
ohnehin auch noch andere gründe für den
rechtsruck und warum in sachsen so wenig
entgegen setzte einen macht er beim
eigenen koalitionspartner aus der cdu
wir haben in sachsen eine sehr traurige
entwicklung in den letzten 30 jahren
erlebt dass so eine verharmlosung von
rechten positionen stattgefunden hat und
da muss man auch der cdu in sachsen den
vorwurf machen die zu lange
zugelassen hat dass man ein teilen
wollte wer der richtige demokratisch was
ist die richtige engagement form ist die
form lust haben die rechts- und
linksextremismus immer gleich gesetzt
hat über politischen extremismus geredet
haben cdu hat auch verantwortung dafür
dass diejenigen die sich für die
demokratie engagiert haben in sachsen
keinen guten standorten sich häufig
rechtfertigen mussten auch verschrieben
wurden als linksextreme in sachsen
wurden alle diejenigen die sich gegen
die nazis engagiert haben sofort linke
nein manchmal nass ist derjenige der
sich recht gegen rechtsextremismus im
gegen die nazis engagiert einfach nur
vernünftig umfragen sie in der zeit die
spd im freistaat bei unter zehn prozent
es wird bei der wahl fiel darum gehen
welche parteien welche atmosphäre in
sachsen erzeugen konnten oder eben nicht
es gibt überhaupt gar keine garantie
dass wir diese stimmung in sachsen die
nach rechts tendiert die eine frust
stimmung ist eine angst stimmung ist
dass die wir dass wir die besiegen
können es gibt keine garantie dass kann
verloren gehen das ist eine wirklich
entscheidende wahlentscheidung in diesem
jahr in sachsen
andererseits den kopf in den sand hängen
ist nicht meine angelegenheit ich glaube
dass diese demokratie stoff ist wir
müssen sie noch machen privaten reicht
nicht
mitten in der hochzeit von p&g das gerät
ihr frontmann lutz bachmann in die
kritik
in einem internet chat wurden ausländer
als gelungen als [__] und als vize
bezeichnet bachmann räumte wenig später
seine urheberschaft ein und zeigte damit
auch wo er sich und pegah verortet
screenshots aufgetaucht die zum teil
bearbeitet und gekürzt worden in denen
ich einfach ko wurde benutzt hat wie
jeder von uns jeder bin ich mir sicher
schon bei einem stammtisch benutzt hat
als päda mitbegründer sich damit nicht
gemein machen wollen scheint die
bewegung am ende und die suche nach
gründen für den gigantischen zulauf der
ersten wochen läuft an
auch die mitbegründer selbst hatten mit
diesem erfolg nicht gerechnet
ich war schon erstaunt über den großen
zuspruch
man muss wirklich sagen wir haben über
wochen gekämpft und haben immer
verdoppelt also wir haben mit 350 leuten
angefangen irgendwann am 20 oktober und
dann hat man 700 1500 also bei uns war
es letzten endes ohne dass man sich
ihnen jetzt noch mal so eindeutig sagen
letzten endes haben sie als medien uns
in die karten gespielt
mit mit mit der berichterstattung es ist
ganz einfach so es sind leute zu uns
gekommen bürger neugierig sind so
insgesamt einem gesagt ich gucke mir das
mal an dann haben die am nächsten tag
gesehen was in den medien steht und sind
mehr oder weniger verärgert gewesen über
die außendarstellung von uns nah das
haben wir natürlich jetzt ist eine kalte
jahreszeit die amalgam garten nicht und
derzeit ja das haben die haben die
natürlich dann ja nachbarn az nach
balanciert ihren kegelbruder ihrem
bruder und er ist natürlich dann auch
neugierig gewordenen letzten endes ist
es wirklich immer so gewesen dass wir
immer verdoppelt haben und dieser spruch
oder bringt jedes mal ein mit der hat ja
funktioniert bis zum schluss rené jahn
wollte damals nicht mehr im fahrwasser
von lutz bachmann schwimmen und
distanzierte sich heute ist er sich
sicher dass es für die protestform auch
schon lange vor 2014 einen bedarf
gegeben hat es hat wahrscheinlich dieser
bewusste funke gefehlt es ist einige
jahre vorher schon einiges schief
gelaufen
das hat natürlich auch damals in die
karten gespielt dass verschiedene
entwicklungen gewesen sind gerade dann
2015 auch die
die flüchtlingspolitik der
bundesregierung dieses herzlich
willkommen von der kanzlerin angela
merkel im september 2015
das hat natürlich dann auch noch mal
wasser auf die mühle geben auch die nun
gegeben und es ist aber auch im vorfeld
so gewesen dass es eine art von
unzufrieden ist hat man schon gemerkt
gerade im osten dass die leute mit dem
namen gesprochen haben gemeckert haben
aber letzten endes kann es in die hand
genommen hat rené jahn hat selbst auch
die proteste von 1989 miterlebt sie
prägten ihn und offenbar viele
pädagogische heute bei begeht er viele
leute die bewusst die wände miterlebt
haben die eben auch gesagt haben wir
haben uns damals was vorschreiben lassen
müssen damals vom sed-regime und die
fühlen sich eben jetzt wieder und
irgendeine art bevormundet und das
wollen die leute nicht deswegen sind sie
wahrscheinlich so empfänglich deswegen
ist der altersdurchschnitt bei baby da
eben auch der wie jetzt noch ist wie er
von anfang an war also wie gesagt leute
die wirklich bewusst die wände miterlebt
haben und sagen wir wollen das nicht
noch mal
rené jahn will inzwischen selbst in die
politik
ende mai hat er den einzug in den
dresdner stadtrat knapp verpasst auch
bei p&g da ist er wieder aktiv nicht
mehr in erster reihe sondern im
hintergrund als ordner regelmäßig an
montagen in der dresdner innenstadt wie
hier auf dem neumarkt vor drei
jahrzehnten stand rene jahren schon
einmal hier
gemeinsam mit 60.000 dresden an jubelte
er einen politiker zu es war helmut kohl
der hier an der ruine der dresdner
frauenkirche ein versprechen gab
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die einheit einheit rufen die sich aus
dem jubeln heraus stellten waren auch
für helmut kohl nicht zu überhören
für die stadt dresden ist der 19
dezember 1989 ein wichtiger tag im
kollektiven bewusstsein der stadt dieses
bild im kopf der dresdner wir haben 1989
in anwesenheit des west deutschen
kanzlers die deutsche einheit auf die
politische agenda gesetzt und danach ist
diese einheit nie wieder von der agenda
darunter gekommen wir waren ist quasi
mit helmut kohl gemeinsam die diese
gewaltige politische veränderung bewirkt
haben
dieses bild im kopf vieler dresdner
wirkt nach gut zwei jahrzehnte später
wandte sich wieder ein deutsches
regierungsoberhaupt an die dresdner
litten in der hochzeit von pg zum
jahreswechsel 2014/2015 sage ich allen
die auf solche demonstrationen gehen
folgen sie denen nicht die dazu aufrufen
denn zu oft sind vorurteile ist kälte ja
sogar hass in deren herzen dass
abkanzeln
durch die nunmehr ostdeutsche kanzlerin
war genau aus diesem grunde besonders
fatal weil nun konnte das narrativ
entstehen der westdeutsche kanzler hat
uns damals verstanden als wir die
deutsche nation wieder auf die agenda
gesetzt haben die ostdeutsche kanzlerin
sie versteht uns nicht von da ab war
angela merkel eine hervorragende
projektionsfläche für den guten für den
protest der anhänger bei beckmann kann
das wort der kanzlerin schon verstehen
aber die kanzlerin ist ja keine
privatperson die einfach folgenlos
äußern kann was sie will
es wäre wichtig gewesen zu
differenzieren
die kanzlerin hätte sich nichts vergeben
wenn sie gesagt hatte ich verstehe ja
was euch bewegt aber was überhaupt nicht
geht ist folgende verdichtung eurer
wahrnehmung der wirklichkeit muss
überhaupt nicht geht es euch
hineinsteigern in hassgefühle das wäre
hilfreich gewesen der situation denn
nichts lieben menschen mehr als andere
die sie verstehen sie fühlten sich nun
aber mal unverstanden und enttäuscht
manche von ihnen auch von der deutschen
einheit helmut kohl hatte anfang der
90er eine euphorie in ostdeutschland
entfachte ihresgleichen suchte er
versprach einheit und dem arc zweifel
und skepsis schien ihm fremd 13 5 jahren
blühende landschaften
es sollte länger dauern und helmut kohl
fand damals auch worte für seine
westdeutschen wähler deren stimmen
brauchte er für seine wiederwahl als
kanzler 1990 und die botschaft kam an
die deutsche einheit gibt es praktisch
zum schnäppchenpreis nicht 30 jahre
später der osten hinkt hinterher
vollzeitbeschäftigte in der autobranche
in ingolstadt zb verdienen mehr als
doppelt so viel wie arbeitnehmer in
görlitz ostdeutsche bekommen noch 3,5
prozent weniger rente als im westen und
nicht ein einziger dax konzern hat
seinen sitz hierher verlegt außerdem
sind ostdeutsche führungskräfte
bundesweit so gibt es zb über 80
hochschulen in deutschland
rektoren oder rektorinnen aus den neuen
ländern gibt es keinen einzigen das
alles hat folgen
es gibt tiefgreifende akzeptanz defizite
und aneignung defizite gegenüber der
demokratie im osten deutschlands die mag
es auch im westen geben aber im osten
sind die erkennbar tiefer und auch
breitflächig das hat mehrere ursachen
eine ursache liegt ganz bestimmt in der
über schichtung der ostdeutschen
gesellschaft die wichtigsten
funktionsträger dieser
bundesrepublikanischen ordnung von der
wirtschaft mal abgesehen in der politik
in der verwaltung in der justiz in der
wissenschaft in der kultur in den medien
sind zu 70 bis 80 prozent menschen die
aus westdeutschland gekommen sind
wenn dieser vorgang mitte der 90er jahre
im allgemeinen noch akzeptiert war
wenngleich es auch damals sehr viele
verwerfungen gegeben hat aber wenn er
damals im allgemeinen noch akzeptiert
war empört er jetzt umso mehr weil sich
diese über schichtung kapituliert hat dh
die westdeutschen netzwerke so könnte
man das interpretieren funktionieren
oder die ostdeutschen haben nach wie vor
riesenprobleme damit sich auch in einer
konkurrenz gesellschaft zu behaupten und
selbst auch die spitzenposition endlich
einzustellen ich weiß nicht genau woran
es liegt der andere personelle transfer
der von ost nach west in größenordnungen
sozusagen gerade von sich arbeitsmarkt
konform verhalten der jungen menschen
landete aber im westen nicht in den
chefetagen sondern eher am arbeits band
und so hat sich durch eine
wechselseitige bewegung so dieses
grundgefühl eingeprägt wir ostdeutschen
werden wohl für immer deutsche zweiter
klasse bleiben und dass das nicht zur
begeisterung einer politischen ordnung
gegenüber führt die man ja
möglicherweise als eine theoretisch ganz
gute erkennt das kann ich nachvollziehen
die deutsche einheit und die nüchterne
frage ob sie eigentlich vollendet ist
wirtschaftlich und politisch nach
nunmehr fast 30 jahren sagen ihnen alle
alle soziologen dass so ein umbau einer
gesellschaft mindestens drei
generationen dauert
das ist auch ein trugschluss der politik
war zu glauben also wenn die generation
die das miterlebt hatten rente gegangen
ist dann kommt gibt sie neu für die
spielt ost und west keine rolle mehr
das ist ein trugschluss das sehen wir an
allen umfragen und gerade junge leute
natürlich spüren die immer noch dass es
lohnt unterschiede gibt zwischen ost und
west die spüren immer noch dass es
bestimmte unterschiede gibt wenn man
sich bewirbt wo man herkommt und
natürlich die erzählung in der familie
die dürfen wir nicht unterschätzen
neben der vater stolz bergmann war und
erzählt dass er dann als arbeitsloser
unterwegs war
dann macht das was mit der gesamten
familie wenn es um die ostdeutsche seele
geht dann ist sie so etwas wie eine
seelsorgerin petra köpping hört in
sachsen immer wieder die gleichen
geschichten von menschen die erzählen
wollen was vor 30 jahren im vereinigungs
rausch keiner hören wollte weil es um
die schattenseiten der vereinigung ging
manche dieser geschichten hat sie auch
selbst hautnah erlebt der tagebau der
dann still gelegt wurden ist sollte als
einen teil der neuen seenlandschaft im
leipziger raum entstehen und der größten
oder größten abraumbagger die dort
standen der es an diesem tag gesprengt
worden
und das war eigentlich der startschuss
dass man dort eine seenlandschaft also
eine tourismuslandschaft eine neue
saubere
landschaft schaffen kann und auf der
anderen seite standen dort die bergleute
die eben auf diesen bagger viele jahre
lang manche ihr ganzes leben lang
gefahren sind und die gesagt haben die
zerstörung gerade mein lebenswerk da
habe ich da kenne ich jede schraube ich
habe dort so viel herzblut reingesteckt
und auch gesundheit reingesteckt das war
eine gefährliche arbeit es war eine
schwere arbeit und insofern war der
freud und leid so unmittelbar
miteinander verknüpft als petra köpping
in sachsen einmal für integration von
flüchtlingen war schallte ihr entgegen
integriert doch erstmal uns für sie tat
sich ein abgrund auf weil sich zeigte
wie wenig sich ihre zuhörer im neuen
deutschland zu hause fühlen
ihr buch darüber hat sie mit einer
streitschrift für den osten untertitelt
sie sind hier ein missverhältnis wir
haben so viele tolle projekte die wir in
sachsen auch gemacht haben wo ich
ehrlich gesagt kaum mediale
aufmerksamkeit bekomme und wo ich schon
der meinung wenn das gerade wenn
menschen das hier unter noch
schwierigeren bedingungen weil sie eben
weniger verdienen und und aufgebaut
haben dass das zu wenig kommen
kommentiert wird aber dass wenzel
negativ ereignis gibt was es durchaus in
den westlichen bundesländern ja auch
gibt das wird im osten sofort zu einem
ost problem erklärt und diese art von
und differenzierte herangehensweise die
schmiede die menschen zusammen in eine
richtung die wir sie gar nicht haben
wollen
heute abend zieht es petra köpping an
die uni hamburg in einen workshop mit
studenten
sie versteht sich als botschafterin für
ein besseres verständnis für den osten
und das ostdeutsche protestwahl
verhalten trotz der wirtschaftlichen
erfolge wenn ich in sachsen bin und den
menschen erzählen mensch leute
dem land geht es super wir stehen toll
da kann es passieren dass der ganze
reihe von bürgern aufsteht und geht und
das hängt damit dass sie selber als
person von diesen wohlstand von dieser
entwicklung in sachsen wenig
partizipiert haben das was ich vorhin
gesagt habe dass man eben über abm
maßnahmen über umschulungsmaßnahmen über
niedriglohnpolitik werden sachsen wir
haben damit geworben dass bei uns die
arbeitskräfte besonders billig sind dass
das eine folge hat wenn die menschen
nämlich 30 jahre gearbeitet haben und
einen rente gehen und dann sehen dass
eben eine rente von 500 euro haben von
der sie nicht leben können es ist klar
dass dort eine verbitterung sich breit
macht die ich auch nicht aufhalten indem
ich einfach sagen dass musste damals
ebenso sein sondern darauf braucht
antworten und das ist auch das was wir
heute in sechs läden spüren
damals das land eine zeit in der die
meisten zuhörer in hamburg noch gar
nicht geboren waren die aber bis heute
nachwirkt es geht um das agieren der
treuhandgesellschaft kurz treuhand jener
behörde die die ostdeutsche wirtschaft
marktradikal privatisierte damals in den
frühen 90ern gleich nach der
wiedervereinigung problematisch
er ist dass man hat dieses management
improvisiert sehr sehr von oben herab
dass eine wiedervereinigung management
betrieben es war viel zu tun es war
wenig zeit man hatte angst die
sowjetregierung bricht gleich zusammen
und so weiter und so fort und deshalb
kam es
der eindruck war dass vertreter von oben
herab entschieden und wir haben keine
möglichkeit uns zu werden und damit der
betrieb dicht gemacht und das war die
treuhand stand in den 90ern vor der
mammutaufgabe eine marode planwirtschaft
in die marktwirtschaft zu überführen
ostdeutsche kamen bei den
privatisierungen kaum zum zug
sie hatten kein geld keine erbschaften
keine grundstücke keine bonität am ende
hatten 70 prozent der betriebe
westdeutsche eigentümer ein drittel
wurde abgewickelt von etwa vier
millionen arbeitern standen drei
millionen kürzlich ohne job da die
bundesregierung musste sich damals für
diesen radikalen weg entscheiden auch
deshalb so der historiker
weil sie dem willen der westdeutschen
zur deutschen einheit nicht traute und
die wiedervereinigung deshalb nur
möglichst wenig kosten durfte die
politik hatte sich unter großem druck
die bundesregierung in einer art
zwickmühle hineinmanövriert in dieser
umbruchzeit in dieser revolutionszeit
wenn man auf der einen seite natürlich
in ostdeutschland immense hoffnungen
geweckt hat aber auch den westdeutschen
hat man versprochen für euch wird sich
nichts ändern es wird nicht schlechter
werden ihr müsst nicht teilen es gibt
keine steuererhöhungen und so weiter und
so fort und und das ist ne das ist bis
heute in dieser debatte glaube ich ihm
gern schwingt immer wieder mit also
diese frage bei uns der umbruch was
natürlich den ausgang aus deutschland
gesehen wird der massive umbruch die
umwälzungen die überwältigung durch die
vorgänge und in westdeutschland ist der
blick immer wieder fokussiert auf die
transfers auf die milliarden auf die
umfassenden umbaumaßnahmen aus
deutschland die sehr viel geld gekostet
haben und das erklärt ein stück weit
diese diese dieses versprechen der
politik dass man im jahr 1990 in
wahlkämpfen in politischen
auseinandersetzungen hochgradig auch
improvisiert gemacht hat das hängt da so
ein stück wird auch noch wie so ein
mühlstein in der der sozusagen dieser
debatte um den hals würde ich sagen
und ist auch ein stück weit der kern
vieler ost west konflikte die bis heute
noch weiterspielen der ruf der menschen
in der ddr nach der einheit deutschlands
hat die menschen in der alten
bundesrepublik kalt erwischt sie hatten
offiziell zwar immer daran festgehalten
das ist diese eine deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft gibt und dass eine
deutschland gibt aber geglaubt haben sie
offenbar nicht mehr so richtig daran und
es könnte sein dass helmut kohl auch
nicht so recht dran glauben wollte dass
es eine große solidarität in der alten
bundesrepublik gibt um die finanziellen
lasten die nun durch die
wiedervereinigung kommen würden auch zu
tragen und so zu tun und er hat es
damals so getan als würde das nichts
kosten war ganz offensichtlich ein
großer film wer wissen will welche
folgen die radikale privatisierung nach
sich zog der muss nach großdubrau fahren
in die sächsischen lausitz in die
margarethen hütte hier wurden bis 1990
isolatoren für hochspannungsleitungen
gebrannt und in dutzende länder in
europa und afrika geliefert
die margarethen hütte überlebte die
deutsche einheit nicht
ehemalige mitarbeiter halten ihre
frühere wirkungsstätte als museum am
leben und sie warten darauf dass die
treuhand akten zugänglich gemacht werden
sie hoffen auf eine antwort auf die
große frage nach dem warum
für mich ist der bogen noch nicht
geschlossen für mich war das
unwahrscheinlich dass die politik
wirklich das vorhatte die menschen im
osten mit materiellen gütern zu
befriedigen aber gehen die arbeit
wegzunehmen
das war mir unvorstellbar dass jemand so
unverantwortlich reagieren kann
die tatsache dass das einfach hier weg
an don worte und die vorsätze und dem
maschinenbau anders aufgestellt und
benutzt werden die ist für mich aber
auch nicht so richtig das kann ich kein
verzeihen sagen wir mal so es sind diese
damals modernen maschinen die gleich
nach der schließung wird geholt wurden
für menschen die hier isolatoren
brannten brach damals eine welt zusammen
denn die margarethen hütte hatte eine
ganze region geprägt
wir waren alle enttäuscht
ich muss dazu sagen wir hatten ja ganze
familien im betrieb beschäftigt selbst
ich hatte drei personen aus meiner
familie beschäftigt meine frau und einen
sohn von mir und so ging es anderen
genauso denn wir sind ein ländlicher
raum hier und da sind also einzugsgebiet
relativ groß gewesen und viele familien
sind hier in betrieb gewesen haben
gemeinsam produzieren
leonard jünger verlor damals seinen job
und lernte um immobilienfachmann
hausmeister doch er war über 50 und
überqualifiziert also chancenlos die
hütte hat er damals um zu überleben noch
kredite aufgenommen genützt hat es
nichts
aus dem grunde weil man dann sagt ja ihr
habt ja viel investiert ihr habt geld
schicken
ihr habt also fast 200 millionen in den
betrieb investiert ihr könnt das nicht
bezahlen die dem orchester der ost markt
ist abgebrochen und als diesem grund
hausmittel maschinen die müssen jetzt
verkauft werden
schon damals rief das agieren der
treuhand wütende proteste hervor
denn um die behörde rankten sich auch
dunkle legenden von meist westdeutschen
käufern zb die sich betriebe nur
sicherten einzig und allein um sie dann
kaputt gehen zu lassen der forscher weiß
sind nicht nur legenden
das ist in einzelfällen oder an
bestimmten fallgruppen durchaus durchaus
zutreffend also diese fälle gibt es die
sind ja durchaus auch bekannt aber ich
denke es ist aus sicht dieser
unternehmen natürlich rationalen oder es
ist auch sinnvoll gewesen also man
wollte hier den eigenen binnenmarkt
absichern wollte hier quasi auch
ausländische konkurrenten nicht zum zuge
kommen lassen und natürlich auch keine
neue konkurrenz sich heranziehen im
nahen umland und das macht aus sicht
dieser konzerne dieser westdeutschen
konzern natürlich durchaus sinn
ob es volkswirtschaftlich sind machte
das ist eine ganz andere frage und das
hat natürlich zu vielen symbolischen
oder kulturellen verwunderung geführt
weil eben dann der eindruck entstand wir
werden übernommen von westdeutschen
interessen
wir werden plattgemacht alles was hier
angeboten in ostdeutschland da ist wird
quasi schonungslos abgewickelt und dass
das betrifft nicht nur die materielle
ebenen sondern hier vor allem die
kulturelle ebene dieser und diese
verweigerte anerkennung dass das sitzt
sozusagen vielen älteren ostdeutschen
den stachel im fleisch bis in die
gegenwart
und so sieht die gegenwart hieraus eine
strukturschwache region bis heute der
weg ging der kam nicht wieder und wer
blieb wählt heute auf protest 42 prozent
holte die afg in der gegend rund um
brust du braucht bei der bundestagswahl
es muss darüber geredet werden denn ich
sagte eingangs ich fand es ist ja nicht
das wird treuhand dass sie ja bloß die
vollzugsorgane es ist die politik die
politik anfang der 90er jahre die
zugelassen hat dass hier dieser brauch
passiert ist das ist für mich ein
politisches thema und die ergebnisse
haben wird auch hier der bürgermeister
und bei unserer podiumsdiskussion sagte
ihm fehlt eine ganze generation hier im
ordner
also man ist in dieser hier geblieben
und ist resigniert und wütend oder man
ist weg gegangen
das agieren der treuhand hat ein
ohnmachtsgefühl hervorgerufen dass sich
im laufe der letzten drei jahrzehnte
nicht verflüchtigt sondern sich heute zu
einem negativen mutters verdichtet hat
sagt der historiker
man hat ja heute ein relativ
schizophrenen befund wenn man mit
ostdeutschen intensiv redet weil auf der
einen seite hat man diese negativen
erinnerungen an die nachwendezeit also
wo die treuen anstellt durchaus was ist
wie so eine erinnerungskultur ellerbeck
bank man sagt das ist das symbol für
alles was schlecht gelaufen ist
auf persönlicher ebene sind diese
urteile völlig anders aus da wird er
betont was man erreicht hat was man
positiv was positiv gelungen ist dass
man reisen machen konnte dass man
durchaus auch erfolge erzielen konnte im
berufsleben dass man möglichkeiten hatte
die man in der ddr nicht gehabt hätte
also das ist durchaus gemischt so dass
ich sagen würde dass die diskussion über
diese nachwendezeit uns hilft besser zu
verstehen warum ostdeutsche er als
westdeutsche mit bestimmten
institutionen mit parteien mit
demokratischen prozessen er fremdeln ein
stückweit natürlich nicht umfassen
sondern eher auf distanz sind und hier
entsprechend auch wahlergebnisse also
die wahlergebnisse sehen die wir in den
alten ländern so noch oder nicht sehen
wie sehr manche mit der
parlamentarischen demokratie fremdeln
das zeigte sich nirgendwo mehr als bei
päda die sich mitte 2015 zunehmend
radikalisiert die demonstranten leisten
einem gastredner aus der schweiz der
rütli schule aus dem jahr 1291
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in den tod also die knechtschaft
frauen auf den höchsten gott
uns nicht frühesten vollmachten menschen
hört sich ganz deutschland wir sind das
volk wieder sind das volk wir sind das
volk
die kanzlerin ist hier auf dem dresdner
altmarkt nur das bundesviertel die paar
us-tochter medien sind nur die lügen
presse europa ist die schuldenunion und
dresdens stadtrat
es scheint als nähme peder mehr und mehr
die züge einer politischen sekte an die
sich langsam aus dem politischen system
verabschiedet und ich bin stolz auf
jeden einzelnen von euch dass ich nicht
mehr von den medien und den politikern
ein last der feste glaube eingeholt zu
werden von den medien dieser glaube an
eine lügen presse bildet das fundament
des pedals woher der glaube kommt diese
frage führt vielleicht auch in die
vergangenheit wiedergänger sind
mehrheitlich ostdeutsch und jenseits der
vierzig sie gingen also zu ddr zeiten
zur schule
diese lehrte ein weltbild in dem auch
die westliche presse ihren platz fand
sie hätte den auftrag die meinung der
herrschenden zur herrschenden meinung zu
machen hieß es im ddr schulfernsehen für
generationen von schülern waren
westmedien damit nicht mehr als ein
werkzeug der kapitalisten zum erhalt
ihres schwächelnden politischen systems
ihr selber lieber mitteln jungen fragt
manchmal wie kann sich der kapitalismus
so lange über wasser halten warum
schaffen die millionen die herrschaft
der millionäre nicht überall ab wie
kommt es dass dort so viele ihre welt
ganz anders sehen als sie wirklich ist
sind die leute blind oder gelähmt
gewiss viele wehren sich und es werden
immer mehr
doch warum geht es nicht schneller
darauf gibt es viele antworten
eine liegt in der wirkung der
massenmedien denn die sind waffen der
bourgeoisie zur verteidigung des
ausbeuter systems ein medium wie das
fernsehen der rundfunk die zeitung ist
ein vermittler aber kein neutraler
vermittler von jemand und für jemand das
medium ist werkzeug man muss fragen in
wessen hand massenmedien sind klassen
medien die zeitungen und sender des
imperialismus sind sprachrohr
das monopol kapitals
nach anfänglichem schweigen lud die
politik damals zu bürgergesprächen hier
zeigten sich päda demonstranten auch uns
gegenüber offen und sie zeigten wie sehr
die ddr ihr weltbild geprägt hatte ich
glaube mal die mädchen die werden von
fremder von höheren mächten
ich will mich jetzt ganz vorsichtig
ausdrücken wo ich offen sprechen werden
jetzt die werde ich ja finanziert von
der hochfinanz das ist ja kein geheimnis
und diese hochfinanz hat natürlich auch
gewisse interessen durchzusetzen
wiederum der politik gegenüber
jetzt hat die politik natürlich die
aufgabe die medien zu lenken und die
medien haben die aufgabe das volk zu
beeinflussen ist ja nicht so dass die
alters blues -coach erzielt haben das
war es ja so schön sei einseitig aber
wenn das manchmal auch früher hat nun
die theorie zum zur gesellschaft zum
kapitalismus in heute haben das
praktikum und leider stimmt eben viel
der theorien mit einem praktikum heute
über ein faszinierendes plus gutes sagen
also viele freundschaften voll sind muss
immer bananen kaufen können schöne autos
das ist ja irgendwie gut das kann man ja
nicht vom tisch legen gesellschaftlich
gibt es viele probleme die ich nicht die
ich mich verbindet 40 jahre politische
ddr bildung blieben nach dem mauerfall
unwidersprochen und fast nichts trat an
ihre stelle im vereinigungs raus ging es
vor allem um reisefreiheit und d mark
die demokratie kam praktisch nebenbei
dass sie hier auch verankert werden
müsste
auf diese idee kam offenbar niemand
einesteils gab er seine art naivität
dahingehend dass doch ohnehin
offensichtlich sei dass demokratie
besser als diktatur wäre das soziale
marktwirtschaft besser als der
staatssozialismus wäre und hätten dass
die leute in der ddr nicht so gesehen
hätten sie auch keine friedliche
revolution gemacht in dieser
schlichtheit ist vielfach gedacht worden
und die leute hatten tatsächlich andere
sorgen
als sich sozusagen um die aneignung
westdeutschen politischen denkens zu
kümmern und später sind dann die
westdeutschen mit einer bestimmten
pädagogischen arroganz aufgetreten
und wenn einem jemand arrogant belehrend
gegenübertritt ja da braucht man ohnehin
die schotten dicht und sagt erzählen mir
was du willst
ich glaube die ohnehin nicht im westen
kann die demokratische grundordnung und
damit auch die liberalität man die
vielfalt nach 1949 in symbiose mit dem
marshall plan und dem
wirtschaftswachstum
das heißt wirtschaftliche aufschwung
wachsender wohlstand für alle ging
einher mit demokratisierung die
demokratie demokratisierung im osten
deutschlands nach 1990 ging einher mit
dem gegenteil nämlich mit
arbeitsplatzverlust mit und
industrialisierung mit abstieg in
gesellschaftliche bereiche von denen man
vorher möglicherweise gar nicht glaubt
dass es sie gibt ist eine grundsätzlich
andere erfahrung mit der einführung von
demokratie im osten als im westen
das zeigte sich auch an der wahlurne
2014 gingen nur noch jeder zweite
session landtagswahl
wir haben damals arzberg besucht eine
gemeinde mit nur 28 prozent
wahlbeteiligung um probleme vor ort wie
den erhalt des dorfkonsums kümmerte man
sich aber dresden der landtag und ein
verständnis für wahlen an sich weit weg
es ist für mich unvorstellbar dass
manche ehepaare und das war bei der
gemeinderatswahl so sagen wir gehen
nicht zur wahl weil die ehefrau
vielleicht für den kandidaten und der
ehemann für den kandidaten plädiert
hätte und deswegen sagen sie unsere
stimmen neutralisieren sich wir gehen
nicht zur wahl
das versteht man einfach noch nicht dass
das mit das höchste gut ist die grafik
zeigt das desaster von 2000 einwohnern
in arzberg waren 318 also nicht
wahlberechtigt 1200 blieben der wahl
fern von den übrigen gaben 78 eine
ungültige stimme ab oder ihre partei kam
nicht über die fünf-prozent-hürde
im ergebnis sind also 80 prozent der
arzberger gar nicht in dresdens landtag
repräsentiert auf der straße resignation
die leute sind müde geworden von den
vielen wahlen diesen landtagswahlen und
kreistagswahlen und ortschaftsrat ist
ändert sich plötzlich nicht mehr in die
atmosphäre aus enttäuschung und frust
bricht 2015 die flüchtlingskrise und
erschüttert ganz deutschland doch
sachsen findet nicht mehr aus den
schlagzeilen hier kommt es zu protesten
zur ausfälligkeiten zu übergriffen zu
anschlägen auf flüchtlingsunterkünfte
und zu straßenschlachten mit der polizei
und wenn sich bundespolitiker in diesen
monaten im freistaat sachsen zeigen dann
werden sie bepöbelt oder wie hier heiko
maas in zwickau vom hof gejagt es wirkt
als sei alles aus den fugen geraten
auch die symbolik bei kita wird
martialisch und all das beflügelt
offenbar auch geister die in der afg
schlummern zb den türen ra björn höcker
der anfang 2017 in dresden spricht vom
historischen erbe der nazizeit und von
einer dämlichen bewältigung politik
[Musik]
die landes auf der inc damals um ihren
kurs und entscheidet mit knapper
mehrheit keine distanz zu bp doug ein
parteiausschluss von björn höcker am
morgen nach den bundestagswahlen
verlassen gemäßigte kräfte um frauke
petry die afg und treten nun als blaue
partei bei den landtagswahlen in sachsen
an mit der afd
haben sie gebrochen ich glaube nicht
dass die afg durchsetzt von nazis ist
aber ich bin ganz fest überzeugt dass es
einige in führungspositionen gibt die
derartig laut sind dass sie alles andere
überschatten
der politische aschermittwoch 2018 in
pirna zeigt was damit gemeint ist die
tonlage sieht deutlich an
die die türken haben ja auch einige
heute weltweit genutzte auffindung
hervorgebracht zb das kondom bereits vor
800 jahren nutzten die türken shops der
malz kondome erst 400 jahre später
klauten die engländer dieser erfindung
und vermarkteten sie in europa mit einer
kleinen veränderung
sie ließen das schaf und dem drumherum
weg es ist nicht allein der witz der
tief blicken lässt es ist vielmehr der
applaus den er bekommt bei
demonstrationen im sommer 2018 in
chemnitz zeigt sich sachsens fdp spitze
auch öffentlich neben görke und pepita
vertretern in einem demonstrationszug
der auch rechtsextreme anzieht eine
partei mit einem radikalen und mit einem
bürgerlichen antlitz der analytiker in
mir sagt es ist zu erwarten dass die
spannungen in der afd
mehr und mehr zu nehmen und eine
rechtsradikale afd wird wesentlich
weniger wen unterstützung haben als eine
afd die sozusagen allgemeinen system
protest von rechts in sich vereint und
sozusagen auch als korrektiv der union
wahrgenommen wird und aus spannungen
dürften in absehbarer zeit auch
spaltungstendenzen werden 2009 10
startet die afg sachsen mit einer art
doppelstrategie ins landtags war ja die
parteispitze ruft zur vorsicht im umgang
mit der presse auf und dazu sich im ton
zu mäßigen und auch keine
menschengruppen mehr zu verunglimpfen
weil damit das feindbild bestätigt würde
andererseits werden schwarzen listen von
unliebsamen reportern in aussicht
gestellt so steht der parteitag in
markneukirchen im zeichen der moderaten
töne doch beifall brandet vor allem
immer dann auf wenn ein redner druck vom
kessel lässt
und wir haben die türken nicht vor ihnen
geschlagen um ihn jetzt berlin zu
überlassen
die redner wissen wofür es applaus gibt
wählen sie ansprechen müssen und vor
allem wo nationalistische töne fallen
hier offenbar auf fruchtbaren boden
gerade im osten und auch das hat
womöglich etwas mit der ddr und mit
ihrem ende zu tun
dieser weltanschauung start war in sinn
konstrukt jedenfalls in der ersten und
zweiten phase am ende dann sicherlich
nicht mehr aber in der entstehung und im
herzen der ddr-zeit war es ein konstrukt
das auch religionsersatz charakter trug
es gab eine verheißung am ende der
zeiten wird der kommunismus einmal
kommen das ganze hat einen sinn und ich
bin teil dieses großen sinn konstrukt
das ich habe einen sicheren platz und
ich habe ideale an die ich mich halten
sollte das hat eine ganze zeit lang ganz
gut funktioniert war dann in kürzester
zeit passe ich habe mich damals schon
gefragt was tritt an die stelle ganz
ohne orientierungswissen kann kein
mensch leben
der neoliberalismus der den einzelnen
auf sich selbst geworfen hat der ihn zur
anstrengung zur leistung zur konkurrenz
im wettbewerb getrieben hat der ski
nation ist faszinierend er hat neue
enttäuschungen produziert geht nicht
anders wo permanent gewinner gesucht
werden werden permanent verlierer
produziert diesen neuen verlust zu
kompensieren bot sich dann der nächste
an
und das erfolgreich bis heute dass der
nationalismus
denn er gibt dem einzelnen drei dinge
die er braucht anerkennung wertschätzung
und zugehörigkeit genau die drei dinge
diese westliche liberale pluralistische
neoliberales tische welt überhaupt nicht
mehr anzubieten hat und deswegen ist er
im osten besonders erfolgreich
die ddr hat er sich immer als das
bessere deutschland verkauft als das
sozialere und vor allem als dass
deutschland das den faschismus wirklich
hinter sich gelassen hatte neonazis
waren in dieser doktrin undenkbar
eine wirkliche debatte aber etwa um
individuelle schuld wurde in der ddr
vermieten
es war leicht sich sozusagen unter der
offiziellen decke des antifaschismus zu
verstecken und die frage nach der
eigenen mittäterschaft auszublenden
ich habe für jeder mensch geburtstag
aber ich habe das zweifelhafte vergnügen
am 20 april geburtstag zu haben
und ich kann ihnen erzählen dass
spätestens ab mitte der 80er jahre an
diesem tag große geburtstagspartys in
den dörfern aus sachsens stattgefunden
haben und das war nicht
geburtstagspartys für mich sondern in
memoriam adolf hitler
das heißt es gab die ganze zeit über
offenbar in der ddr ein subkutanen neo
nationalsozialismus der ja auch noch den
scheck an sich trug oppositionell zu
sein und gegen die offizielle ja so
abgelehntes staatsstrukturen des
national des sozialismus einhergehen die
sächsische fdp weist eine gedankliche
nähe zur ns zeit immer wieder weit von
sich jedenfalls uns journalisten
gegenüber bei ihren wählern aber greifen
afd politiker solche stimmungen auch
schon mal auf oder treten ihn zumindest
nicht entgegen
ein infoabend in obbach 2018 es geht um
migration und um die ganz bestimmte
sorge eines wählers
45 die jungs sind am ende
das müsste man nochmal ansprechen
der asd abgeordnete und seine antwort ja
auch wieder zum anfang ich wir erinnern
uns wo wir auch belacht oderbruch
bedacht wurde
wo wir von der islamisierung des
abendlandes sprachen ja und wir sehen ja
mittlerweile das ist realität und ich
finde dann gebe ich ihnen zum teil recht
in einem atemberaubenden tempo
wie werden diese form gebracht werden ja
und das ist ja dass ich gebe dir
vollkommen recht in der weise dass
natürlich eine eigene deutsche
familienpolitik nicht stattfindet also
wer es ist nicht gewünscht dass wir drei
vier kinder haben natürlich wollte man
sich dann ethnische und religiöse andere
kulturen herein
die mit vielen kindern hierher kommen
wollen und die denen man natürlich hier
diesen weg bereitet und auch den die
möglichkeit gibt sich hier anzusiedeln
so nenne ich es ganz einfach und da kann
man in der tat auch von einer gewissen
umvolkung reden dieses wort sollte man
einfach auch mal benutzten mit den jungs
die in nürnberg am gelben geändert sind
meinte der mann die ns kriegsverbrecher
deutlicher kann man seine gesinnung
nicht zum ausdruck bringen natürlich
haben wir tino keller nach dieser szene
gefragt jede person die mich kennt die
mine waldberg meinen wahlkampf begleitet
hat die welt genau dass ich mit diesen
gedanken und nichts zu tun habe ja und
das ist für mich der punkt kann was sie
jetzt konkret an einer fragen heraus wie
man sie darüber denken muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen dass es hingegen
überlassen
das stört mich auch nie weil ich kann
ihre gedanken gelesen ja und ich bin
verantwortlich was sie über mich denken
das stimmt aber ich muss ihnen doch nie
gefallen also wissen sie das ist
wir reden und diskutieren über eine
begebenheit die ich in dem fall in dem
fall sowieso nur relativieren kann
die hatte in diesem in dieser
gegebenheit auch so gegeben es war eine
sehr emotionale große veranstaltung man
über 100 leute da hat mich einer an
dieses dieses statement wohlgemerkt
abgegeben es war keine frage und ich
habe vielleicht nie so reagiert wie sie
es nur jetzt gerade gewünscht haben sich
es bleibt die frage wie sich überhaupt
das gedankengut durch die zeit
konservieren konnte in einem land auf
antifaschistische fundament in dem
nahezu jeder mindestens einmal im leben
ein konzentrationslager
suchte als pflichtprogramm der
jugendweihe gemeinsam ehren frankfurter
adler und pfadfinder aus
die opfer ich glaube wir wissen relativ
wenig über die wirkungsweise von
antifaschistischer erziehung und es wird
oft sehr vordergründig damit spekuliert
als sei der besuch im ehemaligen
konzentrationslagern oder die
beschäftigung mit dem massenmord an den
juden an sich schon immunisieren gegen
rechtsextremistisches gedankengut
also da scheint mir pädagogisch und auch
didaktisch sehr viel dilettantismus
unterwegs zu sein
es gibt ein ganz zynisches wort ich
glaube ich hab's bei einem historiker
gelesen der gesagt hat wenn wir
unvorbereitet und pädagogisch nicht
tiefgründig durchdacht und didaktisch
nicht gut aufbereitet mit jungen
menschen in konzentrationslager fahren
zeigen wir ihnen möglicherweise das
einzige was bei den nazis so richtig gut
funktioniert hat und wenn wir dann mit
jungen menschen zu tun haben die
möglicherweise schon eine affinität zu
einem bestimmten rechtsextremistischem
gedankengut oder neo nationalistischem
gedankengut in sich tragen wirken wir
mit dieser vordergründigen ort der
grusel pädagogik möglicherweise sogar
kontraproduktiv
[Musik]
als im september 2017 die afg in den
bundestag einzog holte sie hier in
sachsen mit 27 prozent mehr als doppelt
so viele stimmen wie im westen und wurde
stärkste kraft
plötzlich waren sie wieder da die fragen
nach dem warum sachsen warum radikalen
ansichten hier so wenig entgegengesetzt
wurde ob es vielleicht am verständnis
für die freiheitliche grundordnung
mangelt und wenn ja warum ein zitat des
damaligen ministerpräsidenten führt
zurück zu den anfangsjahren der neuen
bundesrepublik in ostdeutschland und zur
bildungspolitik
sie haben mit sicherheit ein fehler
gemacht dass wir einfach der 90er jahre
entschieden haben aus der schule die
politik raus zu halten weil wir genau
das gegenteil erlebt haben in der schule
und in den kindergarten dass man
versucht hat über die ideologie die
menschen zu erziehen was damit gemeint
war zeigt ein blick in die archive eine
ddr heimatkunde stunde in frankfurt an
der oder des jahres 1974 arrangiert für
journalisten die schulen schworen die
kinder schon früh auf die
errungenschaften des sozialismus ein
indem den märkten fleißig arbeiten in
den betrieben wird auch in den web wäre
unser leben halten wir die werktätigen
menschen und fabrik motiv wie ich und
die lehrer erzeugten ein stolz darauf
was die menschen für sich und damit für
alle geschaffen hatten ermöglicht durch
die planwirtschaft ein gegenentwurf zum
kapitalismus sozialer sicherheit ein
starkes die rolle von schule war zu ddr
zeiten gilt dass die induktion ihren de
funktion hatte aus der sicht des staats
aber holz heraus die zielstellung die
offiziell staatlicherseits vorgegeben
wurde war dort das einen schulen
sozialistische persönlichkeiten
entwickelt werden sollten
das heißt dann
das auch schule dort zu ddr zeiten
gewissen stempel aufgedrückt bekommen
hat ohne dass die meister der lehrer dem
wirklich nachgekommen ist war aber dass
das erscheinungsbild wie schüler zu ddr
zeiten die claudia und das hat natürlich
auch in die wendezeit hinein gewirkt
dass auch nach dem umbruch natürlich die
lehrer ein stück weit vor ihm sicher war
dazu kommen dass 40 jahre lang nur eine
leere galt die vom sozialismus der segen
wird und die vom unmenschlichen
kapitalismus der dem untergang geweiht
ist
und nun sollten auf einmal die gleichen
lehrer den gleichen schülern den
ehemaligen klassenfeind und seine
marktwirtschaft nahe bringen
dabei zeigte sich gerade die
marktwirtschaft anfang der 90er erst mal
von ihren schattenseiten also genauso
wie früher im unterricht beschrieben das
hatte folgen findet man unbedingt mit
einigen problemen die man hier noch viel
deutlicher spürt also es jetzt möglich
sein dass da so ein starker bruch da ist
es eher so dass vielleicht der ein oder
andere lehrer sagt nein ganz falsch aber
vielleicht auch früher nicht so gesagt
haben das war sicherlich so dass man
sich natürlich nach dem neuen
gesellschaftssystem ein stück weit
gesehen hat noch das leben in freiheit
war schon ein thema was uns was uns alle
gemeinsam auch befördert hat
die unsicherheit natürlich hat schon am
anfang ein stück weit mit geschwungenen
bei schülerinnen und schüler und
sicherlich auch bei erwachsenen ganz
einfach blick darauf dass man ich wusste
wenn es um soziale sicherungssysteme und
so weiter gibt da war ja doch das was
von ddr zeiten her vermittelt wurde
irgendwo präsent und dann natürlich
ängste schönsten rolle gespielt
das musste man erst mal zu lassen man
könnte ja nicht jetzt möglicherweise
sagen das system ist es nicht so dass
wochen natürlich erfahrungen geht erst
mal selbst zusammenbauen
wenn man gerade die wendezeit betrachtet
wo auch eine ganze reihe von familien
von arbeitslosigkeit betroffen worden
sind denn dann wäre es toll gewesen
jetzt das ist einfach nur zu ignorieren
und zu sagen es ist ja gar nicht so weh
sondern man müsste sie auch diesen
sachverhalten
thomas colditz hat nach dem mauerfall
den wechsel von einem ins andere
bildungssystem in sachsen begleitet und
kann von unzähligen engagierten und
motivierten lehrern berichten aber eben
auch von denen die sich damals dem
generalverdacht der früheren staatstreue
ausgesetzt seien und die sich nun
zurückzogen
das hatte aber auch natürlich dazu
geführt dass sich die lehrer natürlich
sehr politisch sehr passiv verhalten hat
das heißt also das ganze thema politik
und auch gesellschaftliche entwicklung
hat eigentlich dann ein schüler nicht
mehr stattgefunden auch als sich der
lehrer nicht nach stattgefunden weil man
gesagt hat wir wollen diesen stempel
loswerden wir wollen uns politisch
gesellschaftspolitische neutral
verhalten
wir wollen jetzt wieder zurück besinnt
auf den eigentlichen bildungsauftrag von
schule und das hat auch wie gesagt so
einer gewissen passivität geführt dass
als auch lehrwart diese frage der
politischen bildung eigentlich
ausgeblendet haben
insofern kann man sicherlich davon
ausgehen dass eine ganze zeit lang da
wirklich ein defizit oder ein vakuum
entstanden ist das politische bildung an
den schulen so wie man das vielleicht
jetzt sich wieder vorstellen sollte
nicht stattgefunden hat das ist auf
jeden fall richtig
ein vakuum das sich aus den wendejahren
bis weit ins neue jahrtausend so
christian demuth arbeitet seit anfang
der 2000er jahre in der
lehrerfortbildung auch er traf dort auf
unzählige engagierte kollegen aus dem ex
ddr schulwesen aber es gibt eben auch
gute gründe warum die lage der
politischen bildung in sachsen eben
schwierig ist und dass ein grund ist auf
jeden fall dass in nach 1990 ganz viele
russischlehrer gab in sachsen die weil
man russisch nicht mehr braucht als
unterrichtsfach dann zur
gesellschaftskunde lehrern geschult
wurden
diese haben dann nach 1990 teilweise
ohne ein studium eigentlich jahrelang
gesellschaftskunde unterrichtet und
haben dann mühsam ein studium machen
müssen
viele haben das nicht gerne gemacht sie
waren keine begeisterten
gesellschaftskunde lehrer
es war die hatten und das ist eines der
grundprobleme in sachsen das unheimlich
viel
russisch lehrer zur gesellschaftskunde
lehrern gemacht wurden die nicht
brannten für demokratie die weniger
ahnung hatten von politik und viele
junge absolventen die gesellschaftskunde
an den universitäten studiert hatten die
hatten wir haben hier keinen job
bekommen und mussten gehen
aus arbeitnehmersicht war das genau die
richtige entscheidung weil man konnte ja
nicht so viele russisch lehrer entlassen
völlig verständlich für die politische
bildung war es eher eine katastrophe
dabei hätte die politik wissen können
wie schwer sich demokratie verankern
lässt auch aus der eigenen deutschen
geschichte man hat gesagt mit der
deutschen einheit ist alles super alle
sind vereinigt und damit sind jetzt alle
demokraten weil natürlich auch gesagt
wurde die ostdeutschen haben die
friedliche revolution erkämpft und
deswegen sind das jetzt alles demokraten
das war natürlich mitnichten so erstens
weil nicht eine absolute minderheit der
leute überhaupt auf der straße waren bis
zum november und demonstriert haben und
viele natürlich wirklich keine ahnung
haben hatten von demokratie und da darf
man auch wieder nicht mit negativ auf
die ostdeutschen gucken
man muss dann noch mal nach
westdeutschland in die 50er 60er jahre
schauen wie undemokratisch wie wie
rückständig wie antidemokratisch auch
narzisstisch immer gab es viele viele
nazis in westdeutschland und dort hat
auch die die die politische bildung
jahre lang gebraucht um vom prinzip auch
westdeutschland zu einem demokratischen
staatswesen zu machen
die viel gescholtenen 68er die standen
an der spitze jener die quasi
gesellschaftskunde auch eingefordert
haben demokratische bildung eingefordert
haben und das ist auch in
westdeutschland langsamer prozess
gewesen das grundgesetz hat diese idee
des demokratischen in eine form gegossen
ich würde dieses grundgesetz jeder zeit
verteidigen aber es ist halt das
grundgesetz der alten bundesrepublik
dass dort auch in die köpfe der menschen
langsam eingesickert ist die menschen in
der ddr
dieses grundgesetz 1990 einfach
übernommen beitritt zum geltungsbereich
des grundgesetzes sie haben es sich noch
nicht angeeignet und drei chancen sind
verpasst worden
richtig bedauerlicherweise verpasst
worden das erste das über dieses
grundgesetz debattiert worden wäre
meines wissens könnten meinen dass auch
heute noch tun § 100
46 im fall der wiedervereinigung
deutschlands gibt sich die deutsche
bevölkerung eine verfassung das heißt
diskutiert über dieses grundgesetz das
zweite wie wäre es denn mit mir
gemeinsam hymne gewesen mit einer neuen
gemeinsamen kommende warum musste denn
die der alten bundesrepublik übernommen
werden ja und das dritte ist ja für
meine begriffe ziemlich in der luft
hängende nationalfeiertag
wer verbindet schon tolle gefühle mit
dem dritten oktober kaum jemand außer
dass die bundesregierung mit viel geld
mehr party ausrichtet mein tag der
republik wäre der neunte november das
wäre ein tag da könnten die deutschen
lernen wer sie sind
da würden wir früh gemeinsam zur
synagoge gehen und darüber nachdenken
was die deutschen in der geschichte
alles schon furchtbares angerichtet
haben und abends würden wir an den fall
der berliner mauer denken und feiern den
november als den tag der republik
zusammen zu denken und als solchen zu
begehen würde zwei bis drei schuljahr
geschichtsunterricht ersetzen 30 jahre
nach der deutschen einheit hat sich der
protest von rechts in sachsen etabliert
und die mitte der gesellschaft erreicht
die mitte der gesellschaft heißt auch
die schulen das zeigen forschungen die
schüler seien dabei nur ein teil des
problems
was weitaus schwieriger ist was wir aber
gerade auch in den schulen feststellen
die mit uns zusammenarbeiten
das natürlich auch in den kolleginnen
selbst rechtspopulistische
fremdenfeindliche stereotype durchaus
vorhanden sind und das ist glaube ich
also weitaus schwerer zu bearbeiten was
ich da auch ein gesellschaftlicher trend
in gewisser weise abbildet ganz global
kann ich erst mal sagen dass ich doch
einige lehrerinnen und lehrer die an
unserem projekt teilnehmen
im kollegium anfeindungen ausgesetzt
waren warum sie sich denn für demokratie
bildung für bildung gegen
rechtsextremismus engagieren
rico behrens schuld pädagogen im umgang
mit rechtsextremen parolen
er trifft dabei auf lehrer die schon
froh sind wenn ihre radikalen schüler
wenigstens den unterricht nicht stören
sachsen will nun mehr tun für politische
bildung doch behrendt sieht das
skeptisch es klingt als sei es dafür
fast schon zu spät
wir haben hier in sachsen ja jetzt seit
einiger zeit einen etwas zur politischen
bildung der eigentlich von der hoffnung
getragen ist
mehr politik in die schule zu bringen
auch im funk von gesprächen mit
politikerinnen und politikern
ich habe das gefühl dass das ganz massiv
durch rechtspopulistische kräfte grad
genutzt wird und dass hier eigentlich
ein system was wir schon jetzt ja eben
auch länger besprochen hatten was ich
eher als unpolitisch bisher erlebte auf
akteure stoßen die hoch politisch
motiviert sind und das gern in anspruch
nehmen und gern nutzen im frühjahr sahen
umfragen die afg in sachsen kurzzeitig
auch vor der cdu
die schließt eine koalition kategorisch
aus so träumte die afd davon die cdu am
wahltag in ein dilemma zu stürzen von
dem sie dann profitiert eins ist klar
wenn die cdu erst mal nicht mit uns in
irgendeiner form zusammenarbeiten zu
wollen muss in eine vier parteien
koalition
und da kann ich nur sagen viel spaß das
ist das beste was uns passieren kann
warum weil die grünen in sachsen eher
links sind und die cdu durchaus
konservativ und eine koalition dieser
beiden parteien bedeutet dass die cdu
zuschauen muss wie heilige sächsische
cdu kühe geschlachtet werden und das
überlebt diese partei innerlich nicht
auch bei den letzten europawahlen lucky
afd in sachsen form so beflügelt gingen
sie offenbar nicht mehr nur von einer
regierungsbeteiligung aus sondern wollte
mehr
wenn wir in sachsen regieren dann wenn
die cdu sich der afg unterordnet wir
möchten als stärkere und dominanter
koalitionspartner in so eine verbindung
gehen oder wir sind einfach eine starke
opposition und müssen eben halt weiter
kämpfen bis die mir halten sich noch
deutlicher in unsere richtung verschoben
haben entweder wir bestimmen ganz oder
gar nicht dass es die botschaft eine afd
als stärkste kraft ist in sachsen
tatsächlich nicht ganz ausgeschlossen
als regierungspartner aber für keinen
politischen gegner vorstellbar wenn man
nun daraus schlussfolgert alle
etablierten parteien müssten sich gegen
die afg verbinden
dann steigert das den preis den grünen
und sozialdemokraten von der union
verlangen können für den eintritt in
eine unionsgeführte anti afd koalition
und das mündet dann zugleich das ansehen
der union die er dann in den augen von
vielen als eine nun vollständig
hoffnungslos verkrümmte und für
sozialdemokratisierte partei gilt das
ist ein dilemma indem man es beschreibt
ist es noch nicht gelöst zur lösung
würde ich freilich empfehlen auf etwas
was in deutschland bislang allzu selten
ausprobiert haben
das sind minderheitsregierungen wir
haben im grunde lediglich in sachsen
anhalt eine gehabt als die spd sie von
der pds damals hat er ihren lassen und
staatspolitisch sehr klug war auch wenn
das damals heftig kritisiert worden ist
und wahrscheinlich müssten wir wieder
die möglichkeiten von
minderheitsregierungen stärke schätzen
als wir das in jenen bundesdeutschen
zeiten getan haben als parlamentarische
mehrheiten in einem wenig parteien
system niemals ein problem gewesen sind
das minderheitsregierung sämtliche
probleme lösen würden
das ist auch nicht zu erwarten aber
immerhin erlauben sie es die politischen
kräfte so zu sortieren dass man die
politiker die öffentlichkeit die medien
erkennen mit wem man verlässlich
vernünftige politik machen kann was
wirklich nach dem wahltag passiert wirkt
derzeit keiner vorherzusagen
pd die protestbewegung die den blick so
lange beharrlich auf sachsen gelenkt
hatte wird dabei nur eine zaungast rolle
spielen
heute gehen denn dresden nur noch etwa
1000 menschen auf die straße das war
immer noch am montag licht sie stehen
stellvertretend für probleme deren
ursachen teils jahrzehnte zurückliegen
und die mehr berühren als nur 1000
demonstranten und auch mehr als nur den
osten des landes
wir gehören zu einem wiedervereinigten
deutschland und wenn sich ein teil
dieses landes so ganz anders entwickelt
als der rest
dann hat nicht dieser teil ein problem
sondern hat das ganze land ein problem
und bitteschön auch westdeutsche müssen
sich nicht nur fassaden anschauen sie
dürfen auch hinter die fassaden schauen
und wenn sie hinter die fassaden schauen
dann sehen sie das äußerlich zwar vieles
ganz hervorragend hergerichtet worden
aber die schweren verluste nämlich
bevölkerungsschwund und
industrialisierung aufgabe von eigener
souveränität und sinn entleerung die er
den besten insgesamt erfasst diese
verluste sind eben hinter den fassaden
besser zu erkennen
und genau dort liegen die ursachen für
diese politischen verwerfungen die wir
im osten haben wir kommen als
wiedervereinigtes deutschland insgesamt
nicht raus aus dieser chance uns
miteinander neue zu verständigen und zu
demokratisieren
herum
[Musik]